Hey, what are you up to?
Putting together a playlist.
Check this out.
"Scone Jovi, Bun Direction,
Lethal Drizzle, Flan Duran."
I'm sorry, have you put together
a whole playlist of baking puns?
Yeah, it's amazing.
"Siouxsie Choux, Naan Inch Nails."
-No, no, no.
-"Crusty Springfield."
We promised each other
we wouldn't do puns.
"Ganaches To Ashes."
Oh, please, stop. Please, stop.
"Dough-ana Ross."
Oh, for goodness' sake,
I'll start the show.
Welcome to The Great British Baking Show.
-"Fiddler on the Proof."
-No...
-[laughing] "Whisk and Shout," though.
-Come and lie down.
-"Total Eclipse of the Tart."
-Come on.
[Noel] "Ringo Starr Anise."
[Sandi] Can I get a medic, please?
[Noel] "Bun-DMC."
[Sandi] Now,
it's our first ever dairy week.
There's no point crying over spilled milk,
is there?
[Sandi] This baking staple
will be pushed to its limit.
Urgh! No, no, no. Disaster.
[Sandi] In cakes, tarts,
and the most stunning milk sweets
ever to grace the tent.
[Prue] That's melted.
You'd eat it if you were given it.
As a prisoner, maybe.
"As a prisoner... maybe."
[all laughing]
[theme music playing]
[ducklings chirping]
[indistinct conversations]
I'm still here. What? [laughs]
So, yeah. I'm just happy.
[Helena] It feels like home now.
My voice is back.
So, be very afraid, Mr. Hollywood.
Erm, I can probably call him Pablo now.
-It's week four. [chuckles]
-Bing!
[Michael] Bread week
went surprisingly well.
But dairy's different
from bread, isn't it?
Could ruin it.
I'm apprehensive 'cause I don't do
a lot of dairy work.
[Henry] I didn't realise that dairy
is not only a cow.
There's, like, goat, sheep, buffalo...
Horse?
[Steph] Could go vegan this week,
just based on the whole dairy situation.
Morning, bakers. Er, today we're gonna
celebrate all things dairy.
The judges would like you
to make a dairy cake.
So your cake mixture needs to contain
a cultured dairy product.
We're talking butter
that's gone to Glyndebourne.
That is the kind of thing.
Or buttermilk, or yogurt,
which should make a moist sponge.
-[Noel] You have 2 hours and 15 minutes.
-[Sandi] On your marks...
-Get set...
-Bake!
God, I'm starting to tremble.
I think it's just...
I don't know. It's just me.
It's just being in here. [chuckles]
I like dairy. Dairy's good.
[Noel] The dairy world
is a hotbed of innovation.
Now artisan bakers
are bucking the plant-based trend
and harnessing the very best
it has to offer.
[Alice] I'm just gonna add yogurt.
Well, it's dairy week, isn't it? So...
just got to get it all in there.
[Noel] And with its creamy decadence
and microbial benefits,
cultured dairy is fast becoming
a darling of cake-making.
This week, we want them really
to celebrate dairy.
Now, more to the point,
we want to bring in a cultured milk.
Buttermilk, a yogurt.
[Prue] They can be used
to help moisten a cake,
and it's quite common in Northern Europe,
Germany and Scandinavian countries,
to do that.
[Paul] Where they've got to be careful is,
by adding cultures,
they may overbake it.
It'll dry the cake out,
and it'll almost be like cardboard inside.
-[Steph] Hello!
-[Prue] Good morning, Steph.
Tell us all about your dairy cake.
So, this is my
"Answer to Everything" dairy cake.
So it's chocolate and raspberry.
If you're happy, it's a good cake.
If you're sad, it's a good cake.
[laughs] What's the cultured dairy?
So, it's buttermilk.
[Sandi] Steph's chocolate
and raspberry buttermilk cake
will be topped with a chocolate drizzle,
raspberry coulis and crushed pistachios.
What do you think buttermilk
does to your cake?
Moist and light. Light.
-So, a little bit of a spongy texture.
-Why?
-Erm... I don't know.
-[Prue and Noel laugh]
Lactic acid.
Do you know, my mum said,
"Do you know why it is?
It's 'cause it's got lactic acid."
-And I thought, "Oh, shut up, Mum."
-[laughs]
[Sandi] Steph's not the only baker
doubting their dairy cake know-how.
[Henry] I think it's, like, old milk.
So, the acid in that
helps it do things. Yeah.
It has to ferment with the
baking powder, maybe?
And a few bits and pieces,
so it ferments a bit.
Yeah.
[Sandi] Rosie's science is,
in fact, spot-on.
And she's hoping her cake will be as well,
with buttermilk, meringue kisses,
and a homemade limoncello.
It's like a lemon cake,
but with a slightly vodka-y kick.
[Noel] And she's not the only baker
who thinks a little limoncello
can go a long way.
Is that just limoncello?
It's basically just limoncello
with a bit of icing sugar.
-Is that spare?
-[David] It's definitely spare.
[chuckles] It's quite strong.
-[Sandi] Give it a go.
-[slurps]
I went for a full mouthful.
-Wow.
-It's quite good, isn't it?
It's just not a sentence
many boys say to me.
[Sandi laughing]
[Noel] David's limoncello glaze
will top a lemon and poppy seed cake,
and for his cultured dairy,
he's opted for yogurt.
[David] I just really like yogurt.
Yoghurt still keeps the creaminess.
I love the tanginess.
Then I love all the cultures,
'cause it's good for the microbiome.
[Sandi] And yogurt
is proving a popular choice,
although not always
with the microbiome in mind.
[Phil] It's a thick and creamy
natural yogurt.
And, er, yeah, no half measures on there.
It's full-fat all the way.
[Sandi] Phil's yogurt cake will be
subtly flavoured with rosewater,
and adorned with delicate piped roses.
Proving even truck drivers
can get in touch with their feminine side.
What do you drive
when you're driving your lorry?
Er, a fuel tanker, a 44-tonne fuel tanker.
-Really?
-Yeah.
You got one of them?
[imitates truck horn honking]
-Yeah, it's... [imitates honking]
-[Noel] Have you?
-Did it feel powerful when you did that?
-Yeah.
-[imitates truck horn honking]
-King of the road.
Have you ever run anyone over?
I've done a few pigeons.
-[Noel] "Done a few pigeons."
-Yeah.
-[both laughing]
-Wow.
[Priya] I'm making
a... banana chocolate cake,
with some natural-set yogurt in it.
So, it's in a nice tin.
I suppose this is like
a glammed-up version of my humble...
banana loaf I usually make at home.
[Sandi] Priya's pimped-up
banana and chocolate yogurt cake
will be topped with a toffee sauce
and dried bananas.
Have you got all the flour in there?
-Yes.
-It looks quite split.
[Priya] It will... Yeah.
Yeah, it does that, but it's the yogurt.
The bananas are quite mushy as well.
It'll be all right.
-[Paul] Thank you very much.
-No pressure.
[chuckles] He is literally banana boy.
-Oh!
-[Noel] He loves bananas.
[Sandi] When it comes to a dairy cake,
managing moisture is crucial.
[David] Malt extract.
Just a little bit. Ta-da! [chuckles]
[Sandi] Add too much, and it could be
left fragile and prone to tearing.
This should be fine. It's still thick.
[Sandi] But one baker
is throwing caution to the wind,
with two types of cultured dairy.
[Michael] So, I'm using sour cream.
And if that wasn't enough dairy,
I'm gonna make a cheesecake swirl,
because my cake's quite soft.
That's, like, a weak spot,
so it can tear at the weak spot.
Can, hopefully won't.
[Noel] Michael's hoping his delicate
raspberry cheesecake swirl
will perfectly enhance
his sour lemon cake.
[Michael] I'm feeling anxious.
I made this cake ten times this week.
Wow. You must have very fat friends.
It's all gone in the bin
'cause it didn't work.
-Oh?
-It only worked once.
Come on, bakers, a bit of cheering!
Yay!
Round of applause
for half an hour through the bake.
Everyone's like, "I'm not cheering."
-[Sandi] Nobody listening.
-Bakers, I've just spoken to Paul.
He's getting rid of nine of you this week.
You heard that, didn't you?
[exhales sharply]
Okay, we'll go into the oven.
It's on 170.
[Priya] I will check it at 40 minutes.
Forty minutes I'm popping it
in the oven for now.
In practice, it's torn,
it's been underbaked,
it's been overbaked, it's sunk.
So we have to cross our fingers
and pray to the heavens.
[Sandi] Michael might be fretting
about his double-dairy gamble...
but those with a less complex bake
can't relax just yet either.
There is a small matter of decoration.
[Helena] So, I am making
buttercream flowers.
You know, I wanna introduce cute things.
[Sandi] Helena's using her flowers
to embellish
an almond and buttermilk cake.
But, true to form,
her theme is less than conventional.
I'm decorating it as a little ghost.
-Which is what I--
-Of course.
-Yes!
-Yeah. It's a cute ghost, though.
Excuse me, I have to see what's there.
[Helena] Oh, it's a little vampire.
[all laughing]
Prue, just wait.
-Oh, fantastic.
-[Helena laughs]
[Paul] Look forward to it.
-Thanks.
-[Paul] Thank you.
I don't know what to say. I love you.
I've told my husband I'm divorcing him,
so we can marry on Halloween.
-I'll tell Birdy today.
-Yeah, you tell her.
[both laughing]
[Alice] So, I'm making petals and leaves
decorated in white chocolate,
some more dairy.
They're gonna go on top of my cake.
[Sandi] Beneath her biscuit leaves,
Alice's yogurt cake
will be flavoured with cardamom
and pistachio.
I took some in for the kids this week.
Like, "I just made this. Try this."
They were like, "What is it?"
It was like, "It's okay, but it's not like
anything we've had before."
Pistachio and cardamom
is quite an interesting combination,
but, you know, you've got to
try out some different things.
[Noel] And when it comes to decoration,
one baker is determined
to try out everything.
I have got pecan crumble,
and then I've got
rhubarb-flavoured meringue kisses,
and I've got apple crisps,
and I've got freeze-dried raspberries.
[Noel] Michelle's highly-finished
buttermilk cake
will be flavoured with rhubarb and apples,
and topped with a custard buttercream,
evoking memories of her childhood.
[Michelle] When I was young,
I used to stand there,
stirring the milk for my mum,
and then we'd just add it to and boil.
I love the custard powder. [chuckles]
[Sandi] While Michelle
is harnessing home comforts,
Henry is looking further afield.
[Henry] I've been to Germany
a fair few times.
Streusel cake brings back lovely memories
of breakfast in Germany.
It does.
[Sandi] Henry's Ode to a German Breakfast
is a spiced-apple yogurt cake
topped with apple crisps
and a cinnamon streusel.
[Henry] Here we've got streusel topping.
Might put a bit more water
in this, actually.
-[Noel] How much?
-Er...
-I can't even work a simple tap.
-That's perfect.
-That's enough, is it?
-That's brilliant.
-Thank you.
-There you go. See that?
That's how I got this job.
-[laughs]
-They knew.
Bakers, you have 45 minutes left.
For dairy-dallying.
[chuckles]
[Helena] I'm just so tight with time.
[Michael] My timer says two minutes,
but my brain says now.
-[timer beeps]
-I'm going in. [chuckles]
[David exclaims]
[Noel] The extra rise
from the cultured dairy
means the bakers have taken advantage
of large, elaborate tins.
It will release from the pan, I hope.
[Noel] But the more detailed the tin,
the harder it is to unmould.
I'm worried it's not gonna come out.
[Sandi] You got this.
You're a really good baker.
[Michelle] It feels stuck.
[Sandi] Where? Not this side.
-Ooh! I broke...
-[Michael] Yay!
-I broke the stand.
-[gasps]
Don't worry about it.
I'll find another stand.
-I broke the stand.
-It's gonna sink.
[Michelle vocalises]
-[Michael] There you go.
-[Phil] All right?
[Michelle] Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry I broke it.
-I'll hold it. Sorry, Phil.
-[Phil] Sure?
Thank you.
I broke the stand.
That's fine. The cake looks great.
[Henry exclaims] Come on.
Yay!
[sighs]
[Phil] Oh, no.
It normally comes out easier than this.
Whoo!
What a relief.
[Steph] Uh-oh.
-[David] It's come... Yeah.
-[Steph] Yay!
[Sandi] As the relief
spreads across the tent...
It's always good
when it comes out the tin.
[Michael] It's happening.
[Sandi] ...it's time for Michael to see
if his gamble has paid off.
-[tapping]
-[Michael] Movement.
-[Henry] It's not coming.
-[Michael] No.
I'd run a knife around the middle.
[Michael] Oh, for goodness' sake.
[exclaims] No.
[Henry] It's coming.
-Oh, no!
-[Henry] No, no, no.
[Michael] It's cracked.
It's caught right down the middle.
Pretty much my worst nightmare.
It's unrescuable.
[sighs]
[Sandi] Bakers...
-Fifteen minutes left!
-Haven't got time.
-[Michael] Gonna have to...
-Oh!
[Priya] Are you all right?
Oh, my God. My heart's pounding.
[David] This is like the glaze
to soak into the cake.
[Rosie] Buttermilk icing.
[Steph] Chuck all the decoration on it.
-[Priya] This is lifting out.
-[Michael exclaims]
-[Priya] There you go.
-[Michael blows raspberry]
[Helena] I'm gonna name her Hazel.
[Noel] That is our baby.
Let's have many, many, many children.
Groovy ghoulies.
[Priya] Oh, come on.
-I'm so nervous.
-Okay. Think tranquil thoughts.
[Michael] Feeling quite deflated.
Surely you've got a bit of leeway
'cause you're Star Baker.
-[Michael] Not anymore.
-[laughing]
[David] Wow!
[Michelle] Oh, stop shaking. God.
[Alice] Shaky hands.
[Phil] Stressy-stress-stress.
[Steph groans] Don't panic.
Bakers, your time is up.
[sighing]
Look at it.
Look at that.
If I was at home, I'd put it in the bin.
And that's a shame.
[Priya] Well done.
Well done. Well done.
-Don't be nice to me yet, please.
-[Priya] Okay.
Won't be nice to you. I like your T-shirt.
[chuckles]
-I like your triangles.
-[Alice] The macarons...
[Noel] Now the bakers' dairy cakes
will face the judgment of Paul and Prue.
-Hello, Henry.
-Hello. Are you okay? Hello.
[Paul] The definition is fantastic.
You know, the blades that are
sticking out. It looks great.
Okay, let's have a look inside.
[Henry] The dairy I've used is a yogurt.
It's very delicious.
It's a very nice, light cake.
And that's the whole test.
I love the nuts and the apple in there,
because they actually blend
beautifully well together.
-It's a really good cake.
-Thank you very much.
Yeah.
What's the alcohol level in there?
-Er, it's--
-High.
It's just vodka
with some homemade limoncello.
Perfect for Prue.
The use of the cultured milk,
-spot-on.
-Thank you.
[Paul] The sponge is light, it's airy.
That lemon comes through.
[smacks lips] Rosie, that is beautiful.
-[laughing]
-[Prue] Thank you, darling.
That's the right place for it.
Thank you very much, Rosie.
[Sandi and Prue laughing]
It's both scary and sweet.
[Paul] Its got a lovely, erm,
structure, lovely colour.
[Prue] It's good.
For a madwoman, you're doing well.
[Paul] Pot, kettle.
[all laughing]
[Prue] It's very neat.
Beautiful. Can't wait to taste it.
[Paul] The structure inside
is nice and light.
The lemon comes through.
Poppy is one of my favourite things
to bake with. I think it's fantastic.
I love it, I really do.
So much chocolate.
That is the answer
to everything, isn't it?
That is the answer to everything.
Erm, buttermilk is the dairy in there.
It's lovely, light, moist sponge,
which is how it should be.
[Prue] It is so rich.
A little bit will go a long way.
-Well done, thank you.
-[Sandi] Well done, Steph.
[mouthing]
[Prue] The decoration's
a little disappointing.
-It's just a bit messy.
-Okay.
[Paul] Texture's pretty good, actually.
I'm not getting a lot of rose.
You could have dialled that up more.
-[Phil] Mm-hmm.
-[Paul] Thank you.
Well, Alice,
I think it looks really, really pretty.
[Paul] Let's have a look.
The, erm, cake is a little bland.
[Paul] Where's the lemon drizzle?
Where's the cardamom?
And where's the pistachio?
But, erm, actually, the texture is good.
It's light, it's moist.
Thank you very much indeed.
-[Paul] Decoration is good.
-Very good.
I'll hold judgment
on what the texture's like.
Hmm. That is a lot of chocolate.
And that outside is really tough.
[Paul] Hmm.
But, erm, your banana bread
is beautiful, actually.
It's got such a lightness to it.
Thank you, Priya.
[exhales sharply]
The little meringues
look really beautiful.
[Paul] Okay, let's have a look inside.
It's not as loose and open
as I expected it to be.
Okay.
[Paul] Could be the liquid from
the rhubarb that's dripping in there.
In the middle, it's... claggy.
Is there a Welsh word for "claggy"?
-I think it's "claggy".
-If there is, I don't use it.
[all laughing]
-Hiya.
-[Paul] Hi, Michael.
-Right.
-Yeah.
[Prue] Tell us all about it.
The sticking problem.
[Paul] You've lost the definition.
It's ripped, half of it's missing,
it's cracked down the middle,
the icing looks terrible.
[Sandi chuckles]
[Paul] Okay, let's have a look inside.
[chuckles] That is delicious.
[Paul] Very clever with the raspberry
cheesecake folding through it.
-Tastes great, looks a mess.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Thank you.
[exhales]
[chuckles]
-[Michael sniffles]
-[Sandi murmurs]
-[whispers] You did good.
-Stand up.
-[chuckles and sniffles]
-[Sandi] You did good.
Oh.
Can it go in the bin now? [chuckles]
Sometimes it works, sometimes it doesn't.
It's just a cake.
I know it's just a cake. [chuckles]
Can I jump in the river now?
[Phil] Tough, brutal.
Finished it with seconds to spare, really.
[Henry] That went well.
That's the best Signature
I've had, actually.
Mind you,
that's not saying much, but it was good.
[Noel] Dairy week isn't about
to get any easier.
The bakers have no idea
what they'll face next.
Right, my lovely bakers,
time for your Technical Challenge,
which today has been set for you by Prue.
[Prue] All the elements
are equally important,
so don't mess up on any of them.
[Sandi] Right. So, no pressure.
-Bye-bye.
-Off you pop, kids.
-[Sandi] What are they up to today?
-[Noel] Car boot sale.
[Sandi] Oh, they're selling off
some of Paul's car boots?
-[chuckles] Exactly.
-[Sandi] Hmm.
[Noel] Today,
for your Technical Challenge,
Prue would like to transport you
back to the Tudor times.
[Sandi] With this particular recipe,
Henry VIII liked it so much,
he is said to have kept it
under lock and key.
Prue would like you to make
12 Maids of Honour.
They must have a flaky
rough-puff pastry case,
one layer of lemon curd,
a silky-smooth,
well-risen cheese curd filling,
topped with a Tudor rose.
That was like watching you give birth.
-[laughing]
-[chuckling] Er, you've got two hours.
Which is slightly less
than you need to say it.
On your marks...
-Get set...
-Bake.
-[clattering]
-Sorry.
What is a Maid of Honour?
[Rosie] Baking curd cheese.
Doesn't sound very pleasant.
[Sandi] But the curdled dairy
is just the start.
[Henry] I haven't made lemon curd before.
Haven't made a rough puff before.
Help.
[Paul] Curd tarts, then?
They're called Richmond Maids of Honour.
There's the rough-puff pastry,
and lemon curd in the bottom,
and then a curd cheese.
Then they have to make a stencil
to get a perfect Tudor rose.
[Paul] You're challenging the bakers
on making the curd,
but also the pastry, which can be tricky.
[Prue] I want to see the layers of pastry.
[Paul] Yeah.
[Prue] And you do need to bake it blind.
Or you get a soggy bottom.
-Exactly, Paul!
-[laughing]
I don't want to eat too many
'cause I know I've got ten to try.
But I'm gonna eat this one.
-I can't help it.
-This is good, though. [laughs]
[Michael] Right.
Trying to accept things
for what they are today,
and have fun regardless.
"Make a pastry dough
using the cubed butter."
[Alice] Okay, that's fine.
[Steph] I'm adding some water to it.
An ill-defined amount of water.
[Henry] Oh...
Come on. Then you're meant to roll that.
[exhales]
Take over for me.
I am just so hot, just roll... [chuckles]
There you go.
-That was great.
-You're gonna be fine now.
I can tell you don't go to the gym either.
[laughing] Whoa!
-Well, that was a measly roll.
-Whoa!
-God, I can't even--
-I went to the gym once.
-I hated it.
-Yeah, so did I.
"Add half the frozen butter,
fold and turn. Repeat and chill."
[David] Rough-puff, layers of butter
throughout the pastry,
and you get these lovely laminated layers.
[Steph] Okay. Turning it,
and then rolling it.
As many layers
as you can get your hands on.
[Helena] Oh, no.
It's just breaking.
What is wrong with my pastry?
I'll just add a bit more flour.
That's what I need to do.
I'm putting this into the freezer
as quickly as I can,
to try and keep it cold.
-[Steph] I need some cling film.
-[Noel] There you go.
That didn't work out for me.
I'm gonna go.
-See you later.
-[Steph laughs]
[Sandi] Hey, lovely.
You ever had a Maid of Honour?
-No, have you?
-Yes.
-Yeah--
-Oh, when you got married.
-When I got married, obviously, yes.
-Oh. [laughs]
-Er... yeah.
-But to eat, no.
Right, "to make the curd cheese,
pour the milk and stir in the vinegar
and let the curds separate from the whey."
[Michelle] Just put the white wine vinegar
in there to make the curds.
[David] You get the curds,
the milk solids,
and we just want these solids.
Yum! Curdled cheese.
[gags]
[Rosie] Sieve the mixture
and leave to drain.
[Michael] It's disgusting.
It's actually vile.
[gags]
[Priya] Right. "Make the lemon curd."
Just make the lemon curd.
-[Michelle] Phil.
-[Phil] Yes?
[Michelle] I've forgotten
how to make curd.
Do you make it in the pan,
put the eggs in as well?
[Phil] Yeah.
[Noel] I do like lemon curd.
But when you realise it's just eggs,
butter and sugar, basically...
It sort of demystifies it.
-You lose the magic a bit.
-Yeah.
It's like when I knew what ganache was.
Someone went,
"It's just chocolate and cream."
-And I went, "Oh."
-Yeah.
[Rosie] I'm trying to decide
when to stop doing the curd.
I think it thickens more as it cools down.
That's just the lemon curd.
I'll leave that now
and let it do its thing.
[Sandi] While most leave their curd
to thicken and press on with the bake...
[Alice] Okay.
[Sandi] ...Priya is not finished
with hers yet,
and is keeping it on the heat.
[Priya] I know I need it to get thicker.
I don't know whether
it will get any thicker if it cools,
so I'm trying this.
I can't work any quicker,
because if I mess up,
then it's gonna cost me.
Bakers, you have one hour. One hour.
[exhales] Are you serious?
Wh--
[laughing]
Some people are, like,
going back to pastry.
I'm miles away from it at the moment.
The pastry looks a mess.
It's just...
What's wrong with it?
"Roll the pastry and cut 12 rounds."
I'm wondering what size to go with.
That's definitely too big. Oh, God.
[Michelle groans]
[Sandi] Don't make 'em too... you know.
-That was it. That's all I've got.
-Yeah. Oh.
I started a sentence I didn't finish.
-If only you told me that at the start.
-Sorry.
No need to panic.
[Michael] They're a bit wee.
So that's a lot of excess pastry.
Ooh.
It's taking me ages to do these pastries.
It's so hard, but, erm...
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
I forgot to put water in it.
I mean, it's insane.
There's nothing I can do about this now.
What an idiot!
"Blind bake." Blind bake.
You have to prebake the base.
[Alice] I'd normally blind bake for 15.
Ooh...
Blooming heck.
Everybody else is already baking pastry.
But, you know, my curd is set.
There you go.
I should've been doing lots of
other things at the same time.
[Sandi] Just half an hour remains.
-[timer beeping]
-Oh, that's my pastry, I think.
That's not even going.
That noise is inside your head.
-See you.
-It is!
[Sandi] While most of the bakers' pastry
is out of the oven...
[Helena] It's just...
They're looking a bit like shortcrust.
I wonder why.
[Sandi] ...Priya's has
only just left the fridge.
It's horrendous.
I've rolled it so thin,
it's, like, sticking.
Look at it! It's horrendous,
absolutely horrendous.
What should I do?
Oh, come on.
"Place the lemon curd at the bottom
of each pastry case." Quick.
[Steph] Okay. We're just going in.
"Add the cheese curd along with
the remaining filling ingredients."
Eggs, sugar...
[Michael] Oh...
[Alice] They're very small.
Not fit for King Henry VIII,
that's for sure.
[Rosie] Curd cheese.
Oh, my God.
I think I'm gonna do... ten minutes.
[Michael] We're gonna put that in
till God knows when.
It could be worse, you could have
not even put yours in the oven yet.
-Ooh, mate.
-You could still be cutting yours out.
"Create a Tudor rose stencil."
Tudor rose.
My art teacher would be ashamed.
What the heck does an English rose
look like? I'm Welsh.
[Henry] Done.
There's no Tudor rose. You're kidding me.
Mine are blind baking.
You know what you were doing
half an hour ago.
[Michael] How aren't you crying?
Because we've got no time.
-I don't understand.
-I haven't got time to cry.
-How long's left?
-Five minutes!
-[Michelle whimpers]
-[David] That is done.
So, just out the oven. [groans]
[exclaims] Mine are boiling!
I've got lentils in my soggy pastry.
These can't get any worse.
My gut feel is saying
I'm not gonna be first.
But, erm, who knows?
Oh. Just...
This one broke.
[Steph] We've got to
whack the stencil thing on.
[David] How'd I do that?
[Phil] Here we go.
[Alice] Time is ticking.
[Priya] Absolute catastrophe.
[Sandi] Bakers...
Your time is up.
Oh!
-[Noel chuckles]
-Please place your bakes on the table,
behind your photograph.
-[Michelle] Go bring them down.
-Oh!
Is there really any point?
[Sandi] Prue and Paul are expecting
ten Maids of Honour,
brimming with sumptuous curds,
and large enough to satisfy
the insatiable appetite of Henry VIII.
[Prue] Mmm.
Right.
By and large,
they're almost all a little too shallow.
[all laughing]
-[Paul] They're awful.
-[Prue chuckles]
They're really bad.
-Right, er...
-[Helena chuckles]
-At least they're neat.
-[Prue] Yeah.
[Paul] And there is a form
of something in the middle.
But they're too shallow.
They are baked through.
Moving on. Erm...
Quite a thin pastry, which is good.
But there's no height there, again.
Nice flavour.
-The lemon curd's pretty good.
-[Paul] Okay.
These are flat as pancakes.
Probably slightly more lemon curd
than there is cheese curd.
[Prue] That's a lemon curd tartlet.
[Paul] What?
[bakers laughing]
I'm not even gonna look at that one.
Right, this one.
[Prue] Quite a nice curd, it looks like.
[Paul] There's no height, but at least
there's an effort to put more mix in.
The taste of that one's okay.
This looks like a shortcrust pastry,
not a rough-puff pastry.
You can't even pick them up.
[Prue] That's really lovely.
-It's a new invention.
-Don't encourage them.
Don't encourage them.
-[Prue] Shall we try one of these?
-[Paul] Mm.
No Tudor rose on the top of that one.
And too dry.
Not enough filling.
[Paul] This one looks much nicer.
At least there's some sort of nod
-to a pattern on the top.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-It is flaky.
-[Paul] Mm. Okay.
Baked all the way through.
Shallow again.
Tastes lovely. Good layers of pastry.
[Paul] Moving on.
[Prue] The pastry has shrunk.
[Paul] Yeah, look at the size of that.
Quite dry again. It's overdone.
You can see where it's been boiled.
[Noel] Prue and Paul will now rank
the bakers from worst to best.
In last place, surprisingly...
Er, whose is this?
-What is that?
-I know.
I spent too long
trying to get the curd right,
-and I never got the time.
-Never got anything right.
Ninth place is this one.
-Who's that?
-Me.
Do you know, Helena,
it was just not on brief at all.
[Sandi] Alice is eighth,
Michael seventh,
Phil sixth, Michelle fifth,
Rosie's fourth,
and Henry is third.
In second spot are...
these. Whose are these?
-Don't smile.
-[laughing]
At least there's an attempt
of a Tudor rose on the top.
And so that leaves this one.
Who's that?
Steph, I wish I could say
they were the best
-Maids of Honour I've ever eaten...
-Sorry.
But they were certainly
the best of this lot.
-Well done.
-[all laughing]
[Steph] I came out quite unscathed.
It's a plus. It's a big plus.
[Phil] He put us all on the naughty step,
so, er, yeah. Must do better tomorrow.
I messed up on the pastry.
What the hell was I thinking?
[Priya] I'm disappointed,
of course I am.
But it's my own fault,
it's not anyone else's.
[Michael] Today's gone badly,
but I wanna just enjoy the Showstopper.
Because if I go,
I don't want to go feeling like this.
[exhales heavily]
[Noel] One challenge remains.
One last chance for the bakers
to earn their place in the tent.
[Sandi] I'm gonna start
on a cheerful note.
-Best Technical ever.
-[Prue chuckles]
-Nice cup of tea.
-[both laughing]
[Sandi] Steph is kind of
the good news story.
She came first in Technical.
Who else is up there at the top? David?
[Paul] Er, David. Henry, I think for sure.
Let's have a look at the muddy waters
down at the--
-Everybody else.
-Yeah.
[Paul] Michael, Priya.
[Noel] Priya's was a car crash.
You're using car terminology now.
-So I can compute.
-It's just working it out for Paul.
[Paul] Coming into the Showstopper,
it's gonna mean a lot.
There is a huge potential
for two people to leave.
If two did go, it may really shock them.
Hello, bakers.
It's time for your Showstopper Challenge.
Today, Paul and Prue
would love you to make
a stunning display of milk-based
Indian sweets known as mishti.
Now, your display should contain
three different types of mishti.
That's 12 portions of mishti
for each type of mishti.
-We're saying mishti quite a lot.
-Go with it.
Imagine this is gonna be
a centrepiece for a stunning party.
Or maybe a wedding when me and Sandi
finally get married together.
Aw, I'm getting all mishti-eyed.
-[Noel] Me, too.
-[Sandi] You've got 3.5 hours.
-On your marks...
-Get set...
Bake.
With Indian sweets,
my comfort zone is probably here,
but this is way back.
Everything is worrying me at all times.
What am I looking for? A spoon.
If it all goes badly,
probably go and cry outside afterwards,
but for now, I've just gotta...
Just do what I can do.
[Paul] This Showstopper's
gonna be fascinating.
The Indian sweets are all about vibrancy.
It's about colour.
They are used at birthdays,
weddings, predominantly,
and we want that vibrancy.
It's that sense of celebration.
It's a wonderful opportunity
for the bakers
to see if they can bring
their own imagination,
their own taste and personality
to an Indian sweet
which is still recognisably Indian
in the sense that it's small,
colourful, celebratory,
a real showstopper to look at.
[Sandi] Prue and Paul have asked
the bakers to make their mishti
out of a sweet base called khoya,
an ancient form of condensed milk
that dates back thousands of years.
Khoya is where you simmer the milk down
and you end up with milk solids.
[Henry groans]
[Sandi] And it does require
a little elbow grease.
[Noel] I'll take over.
It smells quite nice.
-I don't trust you to do it for long.
-[both laughing]
In sweetshops, they use powdered milk.
Only nutters do it this way.
So, here I am.
-[Paul] Good morning.
-[Alice] Hiya.
So, Alice, Indian sweets.
-Tell us about it.
-Sure, yeah.
So, I'm doing a kind of
Indian-British fusion on this.
I'm doing an afternoon tea.
Erm, so, my flavours
are kind of inspired by that.
[Noel] For her "Afternoon Tea",
Alice will make a khoya carrot cake,
which she'll serve with coffee
and a slice of chocolate cheesecake.
[Alice] Never done
anything like this before,
-so I'll be...
-Like evaporated milk?
[Alice] Yeah.
This is gonna take, like, two hours.
But you don't want to burn it.
Burnt milk is the end.
-And it ruins the whole thing.
-[Prue] Yeah.
-[Paul] Good luck.
-Thank you.
[Steph] Just checking it's not burning
on the bottom.
[exclaims] It's burnt.
[Sandi] But keeping a close eye
on their khoya is only half the battle.
There was a bit of burnage.
[sighs]
[Sandi] The bakers must also infuse it
with mouthwatering flavours.
[Priya] I am making saffron
and cardamom sweets.
They're actually quite traditional,
and I love them.
They're just, like, my favourite thing.
Absolute favourite.
I used to love them as a child
and I still love them.
[Noel] Priya's hoping
the evocative flavours of her childhood,
lychee, saffron and mango, will be enough
to keep her in the competition.
I love this stuff. Like, I really do.
It's special food,
'cause it's the sort of stuff you have
if somebody has a baby or a wedding.
-It'd be a present.
-Yeah.
It was quite a learning curve
to try and make this stuff at home.
My dad was like,
"I used to make this stuff at home.
I used to sit there for five hours
and just stir the pot
when I was a child in the village."
That would be his job.
I'll come back and be the child for you.
Just do a bit of stirring.
-Yeah, to be my dad.
-[Paul] Thank you.
[Priya] Thank you.
[Noel] Priya is not the only baker
who has everything riding on their sweets.
Oh, the pressure's on, yeah.
So, I'm trying really hard.
I am making, erm,
sweets based on the Indian flag.
The colours of the Indian flag,
which are green, orange and white.
[Noel] Michael's trusting his Indian flag
to hoist him out of trouble.
The orange will be represented by mango,
the green, pistachio,
and the white with lemon and rosewater.
All of which are an homage
to his Bengali grandfather.
Do you feel any pressure
with your heritage?
Erm, I do, but then also,
I don't like Indian milk sweets.
-Any of them.
-[Sandi laughing]
I like that you're making a Showstopper
that you don't want to eat.
I think it sounds wonderful.
-If I get it done.
-[Prue] Good luck.
-[Paul] Good luck.
-Thank you.
[Sandi] While the fight at the bottom
is well and truly on,
so too is the battle at the top.
[Steph] Hopefully, I'm gonna do well.
Flavour? Well, we're going
for some rose and, er, pistachio.
They'll take on a nice pink hue.
Bit of Steph personality
in there, indeed.
[Sandi] Steph's hoping her three mishti,
rose and pistachio, mango,
and date and walnut
will be enough to secure Star Baker.
If you don't win Star Baker this week...
-Please don't say...
-...something weird's gone wrong.
-No, he's...
-[Noel] Setting the pace.
-Who are you pointing at?
-[Steph] David.
-David. David's...
-He's got nothing.
-Ugh.
-Look at his fringe. Nowhere.
Nowhere? Yeah, okay, well,
his fringe game is poor, isn't it?
[laughing]
-His fringe game is absolutely ridiculous.
-We win on that.
I'm just putting kewra water in.
Erm, I had to ask an Indian friend
how to pronounce this.
Er, it's from the flour of
the pandan plant and is very perfume-y.
[Noel] David's showcasing
striking designs and strong flavours.
Kewra water cuboids, cardamom spheres,
and carrot khoya
served on crisp fennel tuiles.
[David] So, there's fennel seeds.
Tell me if there's too much of that in it.
It's not punching me like that.
-Cool, perfect.
-I'm also, not gonna, as you can see,
dive in for a second bit.
Fill you with confidence?
-Yes!
-That's my boy.
[Noel] Half an hour into the challenge,
and the bakers' khoya
is still on the heat.
So, to give them a chance
of getting their sweets done,
Paul and Prue have offered a lifeline.
They've allowed them to make
one of their batches however they choose.
[Michael] So, one batch
with a bit of a quick khoya
with a condensed milk base,
so I'm cheating a wee bit.
[Sandi] While most are saving time
by making their third sweet
with condensed milk...
[Priya] I'm just glad to get one thing
out of the way.
[Sandi] ...one baker has chosen something
a lot more time-consuming.
That is pistachio and raspberry kulfi,
which is like an ice cream, essentially.
It does have to cool,
which'll take a bit longer,
and that literally is dependant
on the freezer being cold.
'Cause I...
Yeah, I'm just gonna hope there.
[Sandi] While Henry may be banking
on the cold of the chiller,
his "Seaside Mishti" should evoke
the heat of a summer day
with orange and coconut complementing
his risky raspberry ice cream.
Huge risk.
If the ice cream doesn't set, I will cry.
I cry at anything.
I cry, like, at Neighbours.
-[laughs] Yeah.
-[Noel] That made me cry.
When I was in that vulnerable state,
they got me to do this show.
Temporary madness.
They made me sign a load of papers.
Next thing I know, I was in a tent.
Sandi, you gonna do the time call or me?
All right, I'll do it.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Oh, Jesus, no!
You have to come out of there eventually,
you know that, don't you?
[thuds]
[Henry] This is worrying.
Come on.
[Sandi] While Henry has an anxious wait
for his ice cream to set,
the rest of the bakers can press on
with their shortcut sweets.
[Phil] Done.
[Sandi] With over 100 different types
of mishti to choose from,
Paul and Prue are hoping to see
the wide variety this confectionery
has to offer.
[Priya] Mine will be small, deep-fried,
almost like doughnuts.
Classic when it comes to Indian sweets.
[Noel] But true to form,
Michelle is opting
for something a little closer to home.
[Michelle] I am making a rice pudding.
My husband's nan,
she used to make the best rice pudding.
So, this is in memory of Ben's nan.
[Noel] Michelle will serve
passion fruit discs and raspberry hexagons
alongside her tonka bean rice pudding.
[Michelle] And my rice pudding,
instead of serving it in a bowl,
I thought it'd be nice
to serve it in a little tart case.
[Sandi] And she's not the only baker
giving these Eastern delicacies
a Western twist.
All the Indian sweets I'm making
are based on an old British sweetshop.
So, I'm making
a nice chocolate coconut bar.
[Sandi] Alongside her coconut chocolates,
Helena's sweetshop will be stocked
with Parma Violets and lemon sherbets.
All will be served
with some unique cutlery.
-I'm making biscuit spoons.
-"Biscuit spoons"? [chuckles]
-Of course you are.
-God, I know. I know.
I knew that I'd come across you
making biscuit spoons.
-Some witchy magic.
-Yeah.
[Henry] Come on.
God, this is taking ages.
[Sandi] For the sweets
that aren't taking ages...
attention can turn to decoration.
Mishti are often traditionally served
as bold centrepieces,
and one baker
is really celebrating with colour.
[Rosie] I'm making
red and yellow sweeties.
And they will be individual ones
with a bit of gold leaf and rose petals,
but there'll also be some tiny ones as
olives to go in the martini glasses.
Maybe, if I get all this done.
[Noel] Rosie's hoping
her fruity and floral mishti
will evoke the elegance
of a 1920s cocktail bar.
[Rosie] Decorations, erm, sat on the side
of my martini glasses.
It'll be blooming colourful.
[Noel] But one baker's search
for inspiration
took him no further than his backdoor.
[Phil] I was just standing
at the conservatory,
staring into space, thinking of ideas.
And I thought,
"Oh, my garden looks a little bit nice."
And that sort of inspired me
to sort of make a little display.
Rockery garden with pebbles,
a chocolate soil,
and Norman the gnome.
And I thought I'll give him a day out.
[Sandi] Nestled at the feet of Norman
will be Phil's garden of mishti.
His elderflower rockery
and pistachio roses
will be home to his blueberry butterflies.
-What's happening here?
-I'm making some stones.
-Stones, and this is soil.
-Yeah.
-Is that real soil, or have you made that?
-I dug it up from out there.
[Noel] Nice. Not bothering
with the baking anymore.
-Just gonna feed Paul soil.
-No, forget that.
-Come on, smash this one.
-I will do.
-Come on, get out of my way.
-All right.
[Noel] Forty-five minutes to go.
[Henry] The ice cream hasn't set.
[sighs] Come on.
[Noel] And while Henry's ice cream
might not be ready, one thing finally is.
[David] The khoya, er, is done.
[exhales heavily]
[Noel] But their khoya
still needs to be shaped, coated,
decorated and turned
into beautiful sweets.
[Alice] Just weighing my balls.
If I get these the wrong size,
we've got trouble.
Henry obviously thinks size matters.
[Sandi] Bakers!
[sing-song] Half an hour left.
-[grunts]
-I need a new bowl now as well.
This is difficult. Ooh!
[Sandi] While most of the bakers
are on their final batches...
That's in a coffee sugar syrup.
Coffee to my afternoon tea.
[exclaims] Ah, come back.
...Henry must fry, mould...
-Oh.
-...and chill.
Juggling all three.
Right.
My ice cream aren't as hard
as I'd like them to be.
Oh, that one's burst.
[groaning] My sausage,
it's just too sticky.
[Rosie] That's not gonna work.
So, one batch, they're meant to be
the god Ganesh's favourite sweet.
Oh, I like that a god
has a favourite sweet.
-It is nice, isn't it?
-Didn't go for Haribo.
[both laughing]
[Noel] Michael may be crafting
divine delicacies...
Yeah, these haven't set.
...but Henry's preparing
to meet his maker.
Come on.
Ugh! No, no, no!
[groans]
[Noel] Henry's didn't set.
[Sandi] Oh, God.
Right. We'll do the best we can
with this 'cause it's not done.
-Can I do anything?
-[Henry] Nope.
Didn't think this through.
[Michael] I've done that, tick.
[Helena] Okay, the sugar violets.
The pink stick's a bit softer
than I'd like.
At least my balls are firm.
-One minute.
-Last minute.
Argh!
Panic mode.
-[Priya] Michael, are you free?
-Yeah.
-On to where?
-God, I've got the proper shakes.
[Steph groans] Panic.
[Priya] Come on.
Jiggle 'em around a bit.
Okay, something you would be sent
at a wedding, I guess.
Bakers, your time is up.
-Well done.
-[sighs]
[Henry] I'm so nervous about that.
Brilliant.
Oh, that's really...
[chuckles] That looks really good.
[Phil] Norman, the star of the show.
[Noel] The bakers' mishti will now face
the judgment of Paul and Prue.
Steph, would you like to bring up
your Showstopper?
[Steph] Yeah.
[Prue] They're very neat.
They look amazing. I love the pink.
-Reminds me of a hot-dog.
-[Noel chuckles]
I'm open to suggestions
of what they remind you of.
-[Noel] Pink Panther's hot-dog.
-[Paul] Let's see what they taste like.
[Steph] Rose and pistachio.
Get the middle bit as well.
Enough flavour in the rose,
a lovely combination.
Shall we try one of these?
[Paul] That's very good as well.
It's a great blend between
the mango and the coconut.
-Clever with your flavours.
-I think you've done well.
-[Paul] Thank you.
-[Sandi] Well done, lovely.
Very neat, very precise, very accurate.
-[Prue] And I lust after this necklace.
-[laughing] It's very you, Prue.
[David] So, it's kewra water
and pomegranate.
[Paul] It melts,
releasing all the flavours.
Really good. Quite aromatic.
[Prue] And this carrot is delicious.
The flavours are interesting.
Excellent.
They look great, 'cause
it looks like an afternoon tea.
The cheesecake is moist and creamy.
[Paul] This one,
that's very pleasant as well.
It is like a carrot cake
but with a much thicker paste.
-Thank you.
-[Prue] Well done.
[Sandi] Well done.
I love the look of it.
It could easily be at a wedding.
[Paul] Erm, that lemon's
probably the best one for me.
-The citrus flavour is strong.
-[Prue] Lovely.
[Prue] The biscuit is beautiful.
That it is so difficult
not to just eat it. [chuckles]
Thank you.
[Paul] It looks very good.
The colours match up beautifully as well.
Really delicious.
You can taste the cardamom and saffron.
It's nicely aromatic, isn't it?
-[Prue] It's beautiful.
-[Paul] The spice blend is good.
[Prue] All of them are very clever.
Rosie, I think
you should be proud of yourself.
-[Paul] They do look nice. Nice colour.
-[Prue] Mm.
[Paul] Very different to each other.
The one I don't really like,
that flowerpot one down there.
That one's my favourite,
'cause I love rice pudding.
-I do, but that's not rice pudding.
-Oh, okay.
I think you didn't finish,
and that one looks a bit, erm, melted.
It's got a nice vanilla.
I mean, the texture's wrong
'cause it's melted, but it tastes okay.
You'd eat it if you were given it.
-As a prisoner, maybe.
-[Paul] "As a prisoner."
-[all laughing]
-Yes.
"Maybe."
Really stylish. I love the fact
that they're such different shapes.
Okay.
Really delicious.
Apricot goes beautifully with the coconut.
Not too sweet.
These little ones,
the almond really lifts it.
Okay.
[Paul] That lemon, that's very good
as well. Thank you.
Well done, darling.
It would've been good
if you could've got a bit more colour
into the actual edible things
rather than from the decoration.
[Priya] They are deep-fried and soaked
in a rose and lychee syrup.
I quite like it because it is fried.
They're quite savoury.
[Prue] Shall we try one of these?
It's very difficult to get saffron right
and that is absolutely right.
[Paul] This one, it's nice.
It's got a good mango flavour.
Very creamy.
Overall, could've introduced
a little bit more colour in.
Nevertheless, the flavours are good.
Your flavours are pretty good.
Thank you, Priya.
I heard good things.
Really well done.
[Prue chuckles] Sorry,
I was just laughing at the gnome.
-That's my dad, do you mind?
-I was gonna say something but I won't.
It's very colourful.
The rest of them are all so classy,
they couldn't do it.
[chuckling]
-A sort of backhanded compliment.
-Yeah.
I'll take that.
[Prue] Try a pebble.
I wouldn't like to eat very much of it
because it tastes slightly fake.
[Paul] You've really gone overboard
with your flavours, actually.
Just hit them with extracts
and then stamp them.
They're all pretty samey, aren't they?
-But thank you very much, Phil.
-Thank you.
[Sandi] Thanks, Phil.
[Michael] Obviously,
yesterday didn't go well,
but today I did it
and that was a personal victory, I think.
[Priya] I hope I've done enough.
They were really complimentary
about the flavours.
I felt proud that I'd recreated something
that I really like.
-It's okay.
-[Phil] Yeah.
[Phil] Not so hot today,
but it's not my thing.
It's like a rollercoaster, you know?
You're on top of the coaster
and then all of a sudden, you drop down.
And you think, "Oh."
[Sandi] I loved this Showstopper.
I was amazed at the different flavours
and the enthusiasm and the variety
and the colours.
-[Sandi] This looks fab.
-[Prue] It's exquisite.
Star Baker potentials?
-I think Steph did well.
-[Sandi] Hmm.
[Paul] I think David's done well.
We have our Star Baker in one of those.
Henry could not get Star Baker.
I mean, he just did three round balls,
which was, you know, we're always after...
-Like a mutant.
-[laughing]
But let's not dwell on Henry's balls.
Let's have a look at
who's suddenly in trouble.
Michael, Priya...
-Phil.
-Er, I think Phil's dropped.
-Really disappointing. Very simple stuff.
-Yeah.
That was, erm,
almost kindergarten playdough.
[Sandi] Oh, okay.
Could be the week for two people?
It very much could be, yeah.
It's very, very close.
Yeah.
Well, bakers, I now have the pleasure
of telling you who is Star Baker.
So, the person who is Star Baker
this week,
er, was very close last week
to achieving the title,
but this week has absolutely nailed it.
Our Star Baker is Steph.
[all cheering and clapping]
[Phil] Well done.
Fantastic.
Well done.
That means I've got the horrible job
of announcing
the baker who's leaving us this week.
The person who's leaving us
this week is...
Phil.
[Sandi] Sorry, Phil.
-[Michelle] What the hell is that?
-Don't know.
Oh, Phil, pal.
[Michelle] What the heck is that?
Oh, my God.
[sighs] Dairy week.
Curse the dairy week.
Still, I had a good run.
Such an amazing group of people.
Fantastic.
Absolutely loved every second of it.
-What are you playing at?
-[laughing]
-It's his fault, you know that?
-[Phil] What are you playing at?
Phil was particularly shocked.
And he had justification to be shocked
because it was that tight,
it was that close.
It was a little bit boring,
a little bit too simple.
He struggled in the Showstopper,
which is why, sadly, Phil had to leave.
-[all laughing] Oh, Phil.
-[Priya] Get in.
I'm through. Oh, God, what a weekend.
It's a massive relief.
I think, "Am I gonna be feeling like
I'm gonna be going home every week
for every week that I stay in?"
Is this just how it it?
[Michael] I knew that Priya and I
were in the bottom.
I feel a bit guilty, perhaps,
for even being here next week...
[Sandi whispering]
...but mainly thrilled for Steph.
Because, wow.
I was so pleased for Steph.
She's a very serious baker.
-Hello?
-[Steph's mum] Hello.
Erm, okay, so, erm, I just got Star Baker.
-Oh, my God. Really?
-[chuckling] Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Bloody hell, Steph.
We're in the car park.
[laughing] Mum, you're not meant to swear.
I'm not meant to swear on TV. Oh, sorry.
I'm so sorry. I can't believe it.
You've got to start believing
in yourself, Steph.
-I know you won't, so it's all right.
-[laughing]